[Music]
hey what is up guys um could be HD here
its 2017 and this is a new BlackBerry
for real this is the BlackBerry t1 and
it's definitely very much still a
blackberry but it's also really well
optimized and updated for 2017 this is a
tough one because I am definitely not in
the target demographic to buy a phone
like this this is the phone for people
who either really really want a physical
keyboard or people who really really
want a blackberry I am neither of those
people but I gave it a shot anyway so
BlackBerry has tried all kinds of
interesting stuff in recent years with
their hard work kind of cuz they have -
they tried hiding the keyboard they
tried a square phone with a coloured
keyboard right underneath the square and
this one definitely brings it back to
classic blackberry this is a 16 20 by
1080 display up top and a permanent
keyboard down there at the bottom
available at all times but in tons of
ways as you can see it's very well
updated for 2017 it's this all-metal
bill that's really built like a tank
tolerances are tight its evenly weighted
and the glass is rounded around the
edges for this near seamless feel on the
hand like the Galaxy s8 and it even has
the antenna bands on the outside of the
metal frame like the iPhone and every
single button and the camera ring are
chamfered so just build quality wise
it's actually top-notch it's not
water-resistant unfortunately but it's
definitely more drop resistant than your
other top shell flagships like Galaxy s8
or like LG g6
and also this display isn't exactly
top-notch I mean I didn't have any
scaling issues but it is 1080p in a quad
HD world and it also struggles in the
brightness Department but when you
consider the price this fits right in
line with a pretty nice piece of 2017
smartphone hardware it also has USB
type-c with fast charging thumbs up
there very 2017 and this mid back is
this I guess it would be a soft touch
plastic with just a little bit of
texture I really like this it's a
reminder that the slick all glass back
is not the only way to enable wireless
charging you can do it this way too
except this phone doesn't have wireless
charging now I'm know jerry-rigged
everything but I think if
phone nine millimeters thick they
probably could have found space for that
you know what I'm gonna say already
probably poison a slit seriously aside
from the water resistance and wireless
charging this phone is built great in
2017 that is a good sign
I think the button placement is a little
bit weird or at least take some getting
used to instead of the normal power
button on the right hand side it
actually has the power button on the
left hand side and then where the power
button used to be is another button
called the convenience button and it's
like an exactly where the power button
usually is but once you get used to this
backwardness it's actually a pretty nice
feature it lets you map to literally
launch any application or shortcut on
the whole phone I set mine to launch the
Google assistant and it lets me because
it's a feature Samsung so it's anyone
actually thinking about buying this
blackberry here's how it does on my five
pillars of a great smart phone in a
quick snapshot not spectacular but not
bad for a $550 smart phone it kind of
falls in the upper mid tier but for most
people not bad isn't really selling
anybody on this phone it really has to
have some sort of over-the-top feature
of some sort of specialty that puts it
over the edge and I really think this
blackberries over the top specialty
feature is customization it started with
the remappable convenience button but it
goes way further thanks to having a
physical keyboard when you're at the
home screen you can literally map any of
the letters on the keyboard to be their
own custom launcher shortcut same thing
you can pick any app or any shortcut
both for a short press or a long press
of that key so each button can launch
two different things when you first
press an unassigned button it'll give
you a suggestion for some apps that
start with that letter but of course
it's completely up to you and that just
makes things so much faster and easier
to launch you could have a totally clean
home screen so I'm after short press of
the Y key for example to just launch the
YouTube app right away so it only takes
me a matter of seconds to get into any
app I frequently use thanks to these
shortcuts in the keyboard and then there
are other advantages to having a
physical keyboard as well besides just
being slightly clicker than a virtual
one for example you can do actual
keyboard shortcuts like control C and
control V and this keyboard also doubles
as a trackpad as a sort of a scroll
wheel so you can scroll through apps and
web pages without getting your finger in
the way of the content which is awesome
pro tip you can scroll
super deep into Instagram using this
method with no risk of accidental double
taps so you're welcome you just got to
be careful not to swipe too hard or you
can accidentally hit the home button
right above the keyboard I definitely
did this a couple times but this is why
I find it most useful in landscape mode
so keyboard scrolling is definitely
awesome here and then when you're typing
of course aside from all the keyboard
shortcuts you can use swiping up will do
autocomplete for the word you're typing
helps with some longer words I think and
then you can swipe backwards across the
keyboard to delete your last word this
one's definitely more useful because we
make mistakes
all the time when typing and then of
course as you've probably noticed by now
the spacebar also doubles as the
fingerprint reader so you can unlock
your phone super quick with just a touch
of the spacebar the biggest button on
the whole front of the phone very nice
integration good use of space there well
done so overall this keyboard gets a nod
from me again I'm still I'm not in the
target demographic for someone who's
gonna be using a phone with a keyboard
like this very much but I could see how
someone could get used to it it has a
lot of tricks up its sleeve I do wish it
had a dedicated number row at the top
and I wish the keys were a little bit
bigger for my hands but it doesn't and
they aren't that's too bad for me all
right so question what's the difference
between an Android phone with a keyboard
and a blackberry key one it's a software
and here on this phone you have a
healthy mix of 2017 new Android
smartphone and throwback blackberry
features that you may or may not find
incredibly valuable blackberry hub for
example is the same as last year it
gathers all your information into one
place from texts to emails to Instagram
and Twitter basically all your
notifications and just piles them into
one place so you don't have to wander
around checking things and then it lets
you dismiss or snooze them with super
fine control definitely useful for some
but for me I just prefer the regular
Android Notification Center bbm you
either use it or you don't
and then all the BlackBerry DTEC
features they're very valuable and work
great but some may completely ignore it
like they ignore other pre-installed
Android security apps on other phones
and then all the shortcuts again this
keeps with the theme of blackberry
giving instant access to everything and
tons of customization here all these
shortcuts in the BlackBerry launcher
give you one touch access to all kinds
of little granular things like checking
battery stats or starting to compose an
text or email in your app of choice
pretty awesome stuff over here I like
this theme and then also on the launch
or any app that has a widget you can
view that widget by swiping on their
icon so I can tell which ones have that
by which ones have the three dots on the
home screen and when you swipe it it
just reveals the widget this isn't new
it's definitely in some other phones and
in some third-party launchers but it's
pretty damn convenient if you ask me so
there's a lot of cool stuff here and a
lot of awesome customization features
packed in that I really like but I can
still say that at the end of the day it
doesn't quite outweigh the cons for me
of having so much of your screen chopped
off by a physical keyboard that I
probably won't use very much but at the
end of the day this is the best
smartphone with a physical keyboard and
this is the best blackberry ever made so
how bad do you want a physical keyboard
or a blackberry it's on you let me know
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace
[Music]